طريقة التقطير الكمي المبني على العينات أو SQD اختصاراً هي خوارزمية هجينة كمية-كلاسيكية مثل Krylov
للتقطير الكمي KQD ومثل VQE وغيرها الكثير. عند استخدام مثل هذه الخوارزميات
الهجينة، قد يكون من المفيد التفكير في أين تستفيد كل خوارزمية من الحوسبة الكمية والكلاسيكية. تذكر أن VQE تنشئ حالات على circuit
كمي باستخدام معاملات محسّنة كلاسيكياً. في هذه الحالة، الحالة نفسها على حاسوب كمي. رغم
أن الحصول على الحالة المستهدفة هو عملية تجمع بين الحوسبة الكلاسيكية والكمية.
القيمة المتوقعة للمؤثر تُحسب باستخدام القياسات الكمية.
لكن بعض الدمج الكلاسيكي للحدود ضروري أيضاً.
في المقابل، تستخدم SQD حاسوباً كمياً لتوليد فضاء فرعي مفيد يمكن إسقاط الهاملتونيان أو مؤثر آخر
عليه. ثم يتم تقطير الهاملتونيان كلاسيكياً بالكامل لإيجاد الحالة المستهدفة. لنفترض أن لدينا
مسألة تهم العلم أو الصناعة ويمكن صياغتها كمسألة حل قيم ذاتية لمصفوفة ذات n صف
وn عمود. ولنفترض أيضاً أن n كبيرة بما يكفي بحيث أن التقطير الكلاسيكي الدقيق ليس خياراً.
سيكون من المفيد بوضوح تقليل أبعاد مصفوفتنا مع الحفاظ على جميع السمات ذات الصلة بالحالة الأرضية. وبالفعل، هذا هو
هدف العديد من طرق حل القيم الذاتية التقريبية، بما في ذلك طرق Krylov الكلاسيكية. لنفترض أننا نعرف ما يكفي عن مسألتنا لنقدم
تخميناً جيداً بشكل معقول عن شكل الحالة الأرضية، لكن ليس بما يكفي لحل المسألة مباشرة. في هذه
الحالة، يمكننا إجراء العديد من القياسات لتقريبنا المعقول للحالة الأرضية المستهدفة. نتائج هذه
القياسات تعطينا فضاءً فرعياً من حالات الأساس الحسابي تحتوي على جميع المكونات ذات الصلة
بحالتنا الأرضية. الإسقاط على هذا الفضاء الفرعي سيعطي مصفوفة أصغر لا تزال تحتوي على درجات الحرية
ذات الصلة. سير العمل لهذا كالتالي. تبدأ باختيار
ansatz جيد. بدقة أكثر، اختر ansatz يتداخل دعمه مع دعم الحالة المستهدفة. سنناقش بالضبط ما
يعنيه ذلك. بعد ذلك، قِس الحالة في الأساس الحسابي كما يتم مع بدائية العيّنات.
ثم استخدم نتائج أخذ العينات لتعريف فضاء فرعي يحتوي على الحالة الأرضية.
ثم أسقط مصفوفتك على ذلك الفضاء الفرعي. وأخيراً، قطّر المصفوفة المُسقطة الأصغر كلاسيكياً.
دعونا نحلل كل خطوة من هذه الخطوات، مع اهتمام خاص بتعريف الفضاء الفرعي.
في كل الحوسبة الكمية، اختيار ansatz جيد دائماً أمر بالغ الأهمية. في حالة SQD، اختيارك للـ ansatz
سيحدد أي حالات أساس حسابي يمكن قياسها عند أخذ العينات.
الحالة الأرضية الحقيقية يمكن التعبير عنها كتراكب لمجموعة فرعية من حالات الأساس الحسابي. تلك المجموعة الفرعية
تُسمى دعم الحالة الأرضية. للحصول على تقدير جيد لحالتك الأرضية وطاقتها، يجب أن يكون لـ ansatz
الخاص بك إسقاط غير صفري على حالات الأساس الحسابي في دعم الحالة الأرضية.
هذا المخطط يمثل الفضاء الممتد بكل الحالات الممكنة على عدد الـ qubit المُستخدمة. نريد
ansatz بدعم يحتوي على دعم الحالة الأرضية الحقيقية.
لنأخذ مثالاً صغيراً جداً لنظام بحالة أرضية s ground هي 8 ضرب
الحالة 1 0 0 زائد 6 ضرب الحالة 0 0 1.
هذا له دعم مكون من ذينك المتجهين 1 0 0 و0 0 1. لنقل أن الـ ansatz بالشكل ansatz 1 هو A ضرب
الحالة 1 0 0 زائد B ضرب الحالة 0 1 0 زائد C ضرب الحالة 0 0 1. بحيث
دعمه هو مجموعة المتجهات الثلاثة 1 0 0 و0 1 0 و0 0 1 وهي مجموعة شاملة لدعم
الحالة الأرضية. هذا ansatz جيد.
الآن تخيل أننا اخترنا بدلاً من ذلك ansatz بالشكل ansatz 2 هو a ضرب
الحالة 1 1 0 زائد b ضرب الحالة 0 1 1.
هذا له دعم مكون من ذينك المتجهين 1 1 0 و0 1 1 الذي ليس له تداخل مع دعم الحالة
الأرضية. هذا ansatz سيئ.
لاحظ أننا لا نشترط بالضرورة أن يكون الـ ansatz تقريباً جيداً للحالة الأرضية. يمكن أن يكون للـ ansatz
دعم أكبر بكثير أو قد تكون المعاملات مختلفة جداً بين الـ ansatz والحالة الأرضية الحقيقية ويعمل بشكل جيد.
في هذه المرحلة، استخدمنا ansatz مدروساً جيداً لجعل الحاسوب الكمي يتبنى حالة مشابهة لحالتنا
المستهدفة. ما يظهر هنا هو ansatz الكلستر الغاوسي الأحادي المزدوج أو UCJ وهو مفيد جداً في الكيمياء الكمية.
نريد الآن قياس حالة النظام والحصول على سلاسل بتات تصف الحالة المنهارة لكل
qubit. تذكر أن تقدير الهاملتونيان كما في VQE يتطلب العديد من القياسات الكمية. هذا جزئياً
لتقليل عدم اليقين وجزئياً بسبب عدد مجموعات باولي المتبادلة التي تشكل الهاملتونيان.
في طرق أخذ العينات، لا تزال تحتاج الكثير من القياسات، لكن الأسباب مختلفة. الآن، نحتاج العديد من القياسات لأخذ عينات فعالة من
حالات الأساس الحسابي العديدة المتضمنة في حالات كمية عالية التشابك. في SQD، سلاسل البتات المُعيّنة تقابل
تكوينات النظام المُحاكى. إذا كان النظام المدروس خاضعاً لقيود مطلقة مثل
قوانين الحفظ في الفيزياء أو الكيمياء، فإن معظم الحالات المقاسة ستكون صالحة. لكن بعض سلاسل البتات
المُعيّنة تقابل تكوينات غير صالحة أو غير فيزيائية بسبب الضوضاء والأخطاء. عملية تُسمى
استرداد التكوين تهدف إلى تنقية هذه العينات المشوشة إلى مجموعة من التكوينات الأكثر دقة.
تتضمن هذه العملية توليد تكوينات جديدة عن طريق قلب بتات فردية احتمالياً بناءً على
متوسط إشغال المدارات وأعداد الجسيمات المعروفة.
التكوينات المُنقّحة تُستخدم بعد ذلك لامتداد فضاءات فرعية لإسقاط الهاملتونيان وتقطيره،
مما يحسن بشكل تكراري دقة تمثيل الحالة الكمية.
دعونا ننظر إلى مثال بسيط للغاية على استرداد التكوين لفهم معناه. لنفترض أننا نقيس
نظاماً كمياً بأربعة qubit تمثل أربعة مدارات جزيئية ونحصل على سلاسل البتات التالية من
المعالج الكمي. كل سلسلة بتات تمثل إشغال مدار. واحد يعني
مشغول، وصفر يعني غير مشغول. Qiskit تستخدم ترميزاً يكون فيه الـ qubit الأقل أهمية في أقصى اليمين.
مثلاً، 1 0 1 0 تشير إلى أن المدارين 1 و3 مشغولان. هذه
القياسات تم اختيارها لأغراض تعليمية فقط. الإشغالات الناتجة قد لا تتطابق مع نظام فيزيائي. في السياقات الفيزيائية، غالباً
ما يكون للنظام عدد إجمالي معروف من الجسيمات. وقد تكون هناك قوانين حفظ أخرى
يمكنك الاستفادة منها لتحديد فيزيائية حالة مقاسة. لنبقَ عمليين، لنفترض أن نظامنا
معروف بأن عدد جسيماته الإجمالي n=2. هذا يخبرنا بالعدد الإجمالي للواحدات التي يجب أن تظهر في تسمية حالتنا
وهو ما يُسمى قيد وزن هامينغ.
مع ذلك، بعض التكوينات المقاسة تنتهك هذا القيد. الحالة 1 0 1 0 صالحة فيزيائياً. لكن الحالة 1 1
1 0 بها عدد كبير جداً من الجسيمات والحالة التي كلها أصفار بها عدد قليل جداً من الجسيمات. صفر
في الواقع. هذه الانتهاكات يمكن أن تكون بسبب الضوضاء في النظام أو أخطاء في القياس. نحتاج طريقة للعودة
إلى تكوينات ذات معنى فيزيائي على الأقل بشكل تقريبي.
هذا يُسمى استرداد التكوين.
لتصحيح عيناتنا المشوشة، نقلب بتات احتمالياً في التكوينات غير الصالحة بناءً على متوسط
إشغال المدار المحسوب من التكوينات الصالحة.
إشغالات المدارات هي القيم المتوقعة لمؤثر العدد المطبق على كل مدار. يتم تقديرها
وتنقيحها بشكل متسق ذاتياً باستخدام الحالات الناتجة من SQD. لننظر إلى المدار 2 مثلاً. في اثنين من
التكوينات الصالحة الأربعة، كان المدار 2 مشغولاً. هذا يعطينا إشغالاً متوقعاً قدره 0.5.
نفعل الشيء نفسه للمدارات الثلاثة الأخرى. الآن نعود إلى تكوين غير صالح 1 1 1 0. يمكننا قلب أحد
البتات من 1 إلى صفر لتوليد تكوين صالح. لكن أي واحد يجب أن نقلب؟ طريقة واحدة للقرار هي
من خلال انحراف إشغال كل مدار عن المتوسطات التي حسبناها للتو.
هنا نرى أن أكبر فرق هو في إشغال المدار واحد. لذا قد نتوقع أن البت واحد يجب أن
يُقلب من واحد إلى صفر. بالطبع، المدار 2 ليس بعيداً. ومن الممكن دائماً، وإن كان غير مرجح،
أن تكون هذه الحالة المقاسة نتيجة أخطاء متعددة على نفس الحالة.
اختيار أكبر انحراف عن المتوسط فقط لجميع الحالات غير الصالحة ليس مثالياً. بدلاً من ذلك، يتم قلب البتات
احتمالياً بحيث يكون الاحتمال دالة للفروقات الموضحة هنا. لنفترض أنه في هذه
الحالة نغير البت الذي يختلف أكثر عن متوسط الإشغال. فتصبح 1 1 1 0 هي 1 0 1 0. سنفعل
نفس العملية للخيار غير الصالح الآخر. لنقل أنه في هذه الحالة نقلب البتين واحد وثلاثة.
بعد عملية التصحيح هذه، لدينا مجموعة جديدة من التكوينات قد تبدو هكذا.
باستخدام هذه المجموعة المنقحة، يمكننا تحديث متوسط إشغال المدار لتحسين الدقة. في حالتنا، الإشغالات
الجديدة هي هذه.
عملية الاسترداد التكرارية هذه تضمن أن القياسات المشوشة تُصفّى إلى تكوينات ذات
معنى فيزيائي، مما يحسن دقة تقريبات الحالة الذاتية في SQD. إضافة Qiskit لـ SQD بها بعض الأدوات
التي ستكون أساسية في هذه العملية. إذا قمنا بعمل جيد في أخذ عينات الحالات في دعم الحالة الأرضية
الحقيقية للنظام، فيجب أن نتمكن من النظر فقط في أجزاء الهاملتونيان التي تعمل على هذا الفضاء الفرعي
ونظل نحصل على حالة أرضية وطاقة جيدتين. في مثالنا البسيط للغاية ذي الـ 4 qubit، هناك مبدئياً 2 أُس 4 أو 16
حالة ممكنة للنظام. باستخدام مزيج من أخذ العينات واسترداد التكوين، نختزل هذا
إلى ثلاث حالات في فضائنا الفرعي المعني. ثلاث حالات نأمل أن تشكل دعم الحالة الأرضية الحقيقية.
الآن نُسقط الهاملتونيان الكامل على ذلك الفضاء الفرعي. أي نصنع مصفوفة M من عمود متجهات من
فضائنا الفرعي المُعيّن المُسترد ومصفوفة مشابهة M خنجر من الصفوف ونضرب M خنجر في H في M
بيانياً. هذا يعني أخذ عناصر المصفوفة في الصفوف والأعمدة المقابلة للحالات في
فضائنا الفرعي المُعيّن المُسترد. الصفوف والأعمدة المُظللة هي تلك المقابلة لفضائنا الفرعي. والمربعات
المُظللة بشكل أغمق حيث تتقاطع هي العناصر التي نحتفظ بها لمصفوفتنا المُسقطة الجديدة.
الآن بعد أن اخترنا الفضاء الفرعي المعني، يمكننا تقطير هذه المصفوفة على حاسوب كلاسيكي
باستخدام حلّال معياري. إذا كانت الحالة الأرضية الحقيقية مكونة بالكامل من حالات في فضائنا الفرعي، فإن هذا
التقطير يجب أن يعطي الحالة الأرضية الصحيحة وطاقتها. وإذا كان لدينا معظم دعم الحالة الأرضية
فقط، فقد نقترب. بمجرد حصولنا على الحالة الأرضية لهذا الهاملتونيان المُسقط، لدينا حالة
مفيدة جداً يمكننا منها حساب متوسط إشغال كل مدار.
سابقاً، كانت إشغالاتنا محسوبة من حالات أخذنا عينات منها باستخدام ansatz كنا نأمل أنه سيساعدنا
على الاقتراب من حالتنا الأرضية. لكن لم يكن هناك ضمان بأن متوسط إشغال كل مدار من ذلك العينات يقابل الإشغال
في حالة الطاقة الأدنى. دعونا نرجع. كان لدينا عينات من حالات حسابية. استخدمنا استرداد التكوين
لتصحيح أي حالات غير صالحة فيزيائياً. ثم حسبنا متوسط إشغال المدار باستخدامها جميعاً.
الحالة الأرضية قد تتضمن بعضها فقط. الحالة الأرضية لهذا الهاملتونيان المُسقط قد لا تكون الحالة الأرضية
الحقيقية لنظامنا الأصلي، لكنها حالة الطاقة الأدنى التي يمكن إنشاؤها باستخدام أي تراكب من
الحالات المُستردة في فضائنا الفرعي. إشغال المدار لهذه الحالة سيعطي طاقة أقل من أو تساوي
طاقة الإشغال المحصول عليه من الفضاء المُسترد. إذن هذا الإشغال هو تقدير أفضل لإشغال
حالتنا الأرضية. يمكننا تكرار عملية استرداد التكوين باستخدام هذا الإشغال الجديد ويمكننا التكرار
حتى تتحقق معايير التقارب. التقطير الكمي المبني على العينات سريع مقارنة
بخوارزميات المدى القريب الأخرى مثل VQE. إنه أكثر قابلية للتوسع وهو متين أمام الضوضاء والأخطاء في أخذ العينات. لكنه
لا يزال يتطلب أن نُعد ansatz جيداً بإسقاط كبير على دعم الحالة الأرضية الحقيقية لنظامنا. إذا لم يُعرف شيء على الإطلاق
عن حالتنا الأرضية الحقيقية، فقد يحتاج SQD إلى الاستخدام بالتزامن مع طرق أخرى للتعرف أولاً على
الحالة الأرضية والاقتراب منها تكرارياً.
يلعب SQD دوراً حاسماً في مجموعة الخوارزميات الهجينة الكلاسيكية-الكمية الناشئة وهو أحد
أكبر المحركات نحو حوسبة كمية مفيدة.